une nouvelle demande de reconstitution
la troisième dans la sphère adama traoré
ça sera ça à traoré appelé hier à une
nouvelle recomposition des faits et deux
précédentes demandes ont été retoquées
en par les juges selon la soeur du
défunt c'est la méthode d'interpellation
des gendarmes qui a causé la mort de son
frère alors âgé de 24 ans c'était en
juillet 2016 à beaumont-sur-oise cette
affaire érigée en symbole des violences
policières est désormais au coeur d'une
bataille entre experts médicaux à ça à
traoré était tout à l'heure avec nous
pour nous la reconstitution est
importante et nécessaire parce que nous
n'avons pas peur de la vérité le 12
février on organise une marche une
marche sur paris pour dénoncer cette
expertise pour dénoncer ce déni de
justice et nous allons continuer le
combat on ne lâchera pas et on imposera
cette vérité cette vérité qui est sorti
à un an
c'est pas moi ça travaille qu'il le dit
ce sont des experts qu'il le dise